This is what I wanna share.
It doesn't matter how far you might rise, at some point you are bound to stumble...
...because if you're constantly doing what we do, raising the bar,...
...if you are constantly pushing yourself higher, higher, the law of averages,...
...not to mention the myth of Icarus, predicts that you will at some point fall.
And when you do, I want you to know this, remember this:...
....There is no such thing as failure.
Failure is just life trying to move us in another direction.
Now, when you're down there in a hole, it looks like failure.
So, this past year I had to spoon-feed those words to myself.
And when you're down in a hole, when that moment comes,...
...it's really okay to feel bad for a little while.
Give yourself time to mourn what you think you may have lost.
But then, here's the key: learn from every mistake...
...because every experience, encounter and particularly your mistakes...
...are there to teach you and force you into being more of who you are.
And then, figure out what is the next right move.
And the key to life is to develop an internal moral, emotional GPS...
...that can tell you which way to go.
Because now and forevermore, when you Google yourself,...
...your search results will read "Harvard 2013".
And in a very competitive world, that really is a calling card...
...'cause I can tell you, as one who employs a lot of people, when I see "Harvard"...
...I sit up a little straighter and say, "Where is he or she?"
"Bring them in."